qué expresión puede usarse para mostrar
la división de 18 cajas en dos pilas
iguales escribe la expresión usando
diferentes formas de escribir la
división encuentra el valor de la
expresión
tenemos que dividir 18 entre 2 18 cajas
en dos pilas tenemos 18
entre dos esta es una forma de expresar
lo 18 entre 2
otra forma es 18
entre 2 y una tercera forma de expresar
lo es 18
entre 2
antes de encontrar el valor de la
expresión pensemos en lo que esto
significa voy a hacer lo mejor que pueda
para dibujar mis 18 cajas
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 llamamos por
menos 13 14 15 16 17 y 18 aquí están y
lo que nos piden es que estas 18 cajas
hay que dividirlas en dos pilas o dos
grupos iguales si lo hago así como quien
dice a ojo pues puedo tomar digamos que
estas cajas de acá
aquí estas 3 también
y mi otro grupo sera
y esto de acá cada uno de estos dos
grupos tiene el mismo número de cajas y
veamos cuántas son 123456789 así que
tenemos dos grupos iguales con nueve
cajas cada uno lo que nos da que este 18
entre 2 es igual a 9 igual este 10 y 82
también es igual a 9 y esta división de
acá abajo también 9 por 2 18 18 menos 18
es 0 con lo que hemos resuelto el
problema nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo